Optimal at this altitude,
I can run flat out for a half mile before my hands start shaking one else.
I'm a cybernetic organism living tissue.
This episode is brought to you by audible,
which has the largest selection of audio books on the planet.
I've used audible for many years and I've several audio books to recommend right
off the bat.
If you're looking for a new one ready player,
one by Ernest Cline,
you may have heard of it.
The Tao of Seneca by Seneca.
If you want to hear my favorite collection of letters of all time as well as the
graveyard book by Neil Gaiman,
which is a fiction book I used to reintroduce nonfiction purists to the beauty
and truth and enjoyment,
affection,
the graveyard book.
It is incredible and I like the version that Neil reads himself,
but the entire ensemble cast is also fun.
Audible members get a credit every month,
good for any audio book in the store,
regardless of price and unused credits roll over to the next month.
So if you didn't like your audio book,
no problem.
You can exchange it.
No questions asked.
Plus your books are yours to keep with audible.
You can go back and relisten anytime,
even if you cancel your membership.
And for some books,
again,
graveyard book by Neil Gaiman,
I've listened to many,
many times.
She may even just start over as soon as you finish it the first time.
Audible also helps you to listen to more books by letting you switch seamlessly
between devices.
Picking up exactly where you left off,
whether it's on your phone,
through your car,
from a tablet or at home on an Amazon Echo,
whatever.
You can get through tons of books,
hands in ice free while doing almost anything.
So that is part of the beauty of audio.
It is a secondary activity when you're walking the dog cooking,
whatever it might be.
Audible content includes an unmatched selection of audiobooks,
original audio shows,
news,
comedy,
and much more from leading audio book publishers,
Broadcasters,
Entertainers,
magazine and newspaper publishers and business information providers.
Maybe that's what I am,
a business information provider.
And right now audible is offering listeners of this podcast,
a free audio book with a 30 Day trial memberships.
Check it out.
Go to audible.com forward slash Tim and browse the unmatched selection of audio
programs.
Download a title free and start listening.
It is super simple.
Go to audible.com forward slash Tim or text Tim to 500 500 on your telephone to
get started today.
Check it out.
This episode is brought to you by freshbooks.
Freshbooks has become the goto cloud accounting software for literally millions
of small business owners who found a faster,
more efficient and much less stressful way to deal with their numbers and
ultimately this helps you to focus on what you are best at.
It is used by many of the fastest growing startups I've invested in or advise,
and it's equally used by many of the best freelancers I work with on a daily or
weekly basis.
It is one of the easiest ways to send invoices,
get paid,
track your time and track your clients if you're self employed and managing
business sometimes means wrestling with spreadsheets,
crumbled receipts,
and other scattered pieces.
Freshbooks can really help.
Freshbooks allows you to do many,
many different things very easily.
Preparing and sending a polished branded invoice takes about 30 seconds.
You can set yourself up to receive online payments from your clients and about
two clicks,
which on average we'll get you paid twice as fast they're new proposals.
Feature means you can include a project summary and timeline is part of your
estimate.
There are many,
many other things.
Tracking your time,
the quick proposals that I mentioned,
formatting free,
super easy,
late payment reminders so you don't have to chase people.
Automatic expenses,
sharing files and messages with your client's award winning customer service.
They are extremely responsive.
The interface is super intuitive and there's almost no learning curve,
so in short it's easy.
It saves you time and right now freshbooks is offering an unrestricted 30 day
free trial.
For all of my listeners to claim yours,
check it out.
Go to freshbooks.com forward slash Tim and enter Tim Ferris in the how did you
hear about us section and that is funky.
Spell t I m.
F.
E R.
R.
I s.
S.
So again,
going to freshbooks.com/tim and enter Tim Ferriss in the how did you hear about
us section,
check it out.
Hello boys and girls.
This is Tim Ferriss and welcome to another episode of the Tim Ferriss Show where
it is my job to interview in deconstruct world class performers of all different
types to tease out the lessons,
habits,
routines,
and much more that you can apply in your own lives.
And my guest today really blew me away.
I implore you,
I beg you to listen to this entire conversation.
I was so impressed from start to finish.
His name is George Raveling and I do owe a debt of gratitude to Ryan holiday for
making this introduction.
George Raveling on Twitter,
Facebook and Instagram at George Raveling,
r a.
V e L.
I n G.
Coach George raveling.com is an 80 year old living legend and Nike's former
director of international basketball coach Rav,
as he's often called,
was the first African American basketball coach in the pack eight pack 12 and is
often referred to as the human Google for reasons that become abundantly clear.
In this interview,
he has held head coaching jobs at Washington state,
the University of Iowa and USC.
Following a prolific basketball coaching career.
He joined Nike at the request to Phil Knight where he played an integral role in
signing a reluctant,
not many people know that story.
Michael Jordan,
he's also been inducted in the Nice Smith Memorial Basketball Hall of fame as
well as the college basketball hall of fame.
We cover a lot in this wide ranging conversation and Austin,
Texas.
We cover how he was given the original copy of Dr. Martin Luther King Jr's.
I have a dream speech,
which was not the name by the way originally how his practice team ended up
beating the 1984 US Olympic Dream Team in basketball.
What the story of getting Michael Jordan,
the signs Nike.
Why coach Rav has been nicknamed the human Google his veracious reading habit
and how he picks books and takes notes.
We had a huge nerd out over how to take notes in books,
the wisdom of his grandmother and other mentors and much,
much,
much more.
I really walked out of this conversation floating on there and reflecting on and
thinking about so much of what he shared.
He's an incredibly impressive human being.
I hope you enjoy this even half as much as I did,
which would mean it's probably going to be one of your favorite episodes that
I've done.
So without further ado,
please enjoy the ever impressive George Raveling
coach.
Welcome to the show.
Thank you
very much.
It's a pleasure to be part of your world.
I have been looking forward to this conversation ever since.
Our mutual friend Ryan holiday gave me a teaser of your life story and when I
started doing homework and prep,
I started thinking to myself,
I should try to get coach to spend the next two days with me.
I should cancel my flights because we are going to barely scratch the surface.
In the time that we have today.
And,
uh,
I struggled with where to start because I have pages and pages of notes of my
own,
and you also sent me,
I will give you credit where credit is due,
the,
the absolute best exploratory bullets at any guests out of 300 plus gasses
setting.
And,
uh,
we're going to start somewhere that I think may surprise people.
And,
uh,
that is the,
I have a dream speech.
So could you,
could you tell us about your relationship with that,
please?
Well,
it's,
uh,
one of those stories about being in the right place at the right time.
Um,
it was a Thursday night and,
and Claymont Delaware and I was having dinner at my best friend's home.
And his doctors are very,
his dad was a very prominent dentists and Wilmington.
And so in the background as we ate dinner in those days,
everyone ate dinner as a family.
And so in the background the television was on,
in the news,
uh,
was,
commentary was about the forthcoming march on Washington.
And so my friend was,
his name Warren Wilson is dead,
was Dr. Woodrow Wilson.
Uh,
and so he asks a question of us,
are you boys are going to go to the march on Washington?
And we said,
no.
And he asked us why not?
And we gave him some,
the,
uh,
you full a excuse.
We didn't have any money or way to get there.
And so he said,
well,
I have a feeling this is going to be a historic event.
It could be the largest gathering of black people in the history of American one
place.
And so he said,
and I think the two of you should be there.
He said,
so what I'm going to do,
he had two cars.
He said,
I'm going to give me a one of the cars and money and you guys should attend.
And so,
uh,
the next day we,
we took off for Washington DC on Friday.
And at that time there was one main thoroughfare into Washington.
DC was route one.
And so when you come in,
you come in off in New York Avenue.
And so there were a lot of what we call motels in those days along there.
And we found one that was suitable to our,
uh,
economics and we got a room.
And so we decided that we would go down to the monument grounds just to get a
feel for the best way to get there and what it was going to look like.
And so as we were walking around,
we encountered a gentleman and he asked us,
I'm sixth floor and Warren,
six four.
So he asked us if we were coming to the march the next day.
And we said,
absolutely.
And so he said,
would you want to volunteer?
And so we said,
for what?
And he said to be security guards.
So we said,
sure,
we'll volunteer.
And he said,
well,
we're expecting twice the attendance that the papers are predicting.
And so we,
we have to add a additional security.
So he said,
well,
meet you down there the next morning at eight 15.
And so we got there early.
Uh,
we woke up,
we were all excited.
So we get down there and we find him and he said,
wow,
you guys are really early.
And so he looks at how tall we are.
And he says,
well,
we've decided we're going to put extra security up on the podium and so we're
going to sign you guys to the podium.
And um,
and so they had these little white hats,
which uh,
maybe like a sailor hat,
but their cardboard that the wear for identification.
So we were stationed at the podium where all those speakers we're going to.
Uh,
so to give you some backdrop on it,
that all the speakers and they start at nine o'clock in the morning.
If I remember correctly,
John Lewis was the first speaker and then there was a series of speakers
throughout the day concluding with Martin Luther King as the last speaker.
Some people would suggest that it was,
he was a keynote speaker,
but he really wasn't.
They put king last because they knew he would hold the crowd.
So part of the stipulation was each speaker had to submit in writing his speech
that he was going to give.
And that could or could not exceed five minutes.
There was a hard and fast rule on this.
And what was interesting about it was that James Baldwin submitted his speech
and he,
and,
uh,
they felt it was too exclamatory.
They,
they were worried about getting the crowd to excited and maybe having a
demonstration.
And,
and Baldwin speech was over five minutes and so they wouldn't accept it.
So Baldwin [inaudible] refused to speak,
but he was originally to be one of the speakers.
So as the day goes on,
it's a hot and humid day.
And,
and as you look out from the Lincoln Memorial,
you look out to what they call a reflecting pool all the way back to the
Washington monument.
And as the longer the day when the hotter it became,
uh,
the more energized people were.
Uh,
and so we finally get to that point,
uh,
of the,
the end of the day,
and Martin Luther King comes on to speak.
And so as history,
we'll,
we'll show a kink speaks.
Uh,
he's speaking from prepared notes and he gets to about a one paragraph left.
And then as he's speaking to crowds,
as,
as it's just mesmerized by him,
he,
he has captured every single ounce of attention in each human being.
And,
uh,
and he had a cadence about the way spoke that he would say how long?
And he had these,
what I call drum beats,
and he had a way of,
of raising and lowering his voice to,
to manipulate you as a listener.
And,
and so he's just about toward the end of this,
uh,
the last,
going to the last paragraph and you hear a voice.
And today with technology,
you could certainly do it.
Uh,
but the female voice front seated behind the podium says,
tell them about the dream Martin.
Tell them about the dream.
Well,
the voice was that of Mahalia Jackson,
who most people would say is the greatest Gospel,
Black Gospel singers of all time,
maybe the greatest gospel singer of all time.
She had worked on previous,
uh,
demonstrations and gatherings with Martin Luther King.
So she had heard Martin Luther King tell the,
I have a dream part in Selma and,
and Detroit.
And so if you look at the original speech,
it was not part of the original speech.
And second,
he's the only speaker who exceeded five minutes.
And so at that point,
the crowd is just mesmerized by him and saw him and he ad libs in the,
I have a dream speech and then he,
and then at the conclusion he goes back and closes out with the prepared,
uh,
closing.
So when it's over for,
uh,
we,
we were told to form of v around the podium and help the usher him out.
So it justice,
he finishes,
uh,
I s the most frequently asked question is,
is why did you ask him for the speech?
I have no idea.
It's just impulse.
So I say to him,
to Dr. King as he's falling the speech,
I said,
Dr. King could have had that copy of the speech and,
and just as he's folding,
and he instinctively hands it to me,
and,
and then a rabbi who's doing the Benediction says,
Dr. King Nuts,
a great speech that I am so inspired.
So as the attention shifted away from me to the rabbi.
And so,
uh,
we,
when the Rab,
I finished a benediction.
I actually,
CBS went through the archives of Johnson and Johnson,
Ebony magazine and they found a picture of me standing right beside him at the
podium.
So I,
I actually have a picture that verifies that I was there and CBS was able to
find some footage where he was folding this,
that's the speech.
And they can see him hand in that,
but,
but didn't show my hand.
And,
and so at any rate when it's over,
uh,
they go over to the White House and as they walk into the Oval Office,
President Kennedy says,
Dr. King,
I loved your,
I have a dream speech.
Well,
so the media took that and ran with it because if you see the original speech,
the speech had no title.
And so little did I know at that time that this was going to take on the
historic significance that it did actually took 50 years for it to really find
its rightful place in history.
It's makes me mindful of something that heard Malcolm x say one time,
then history is best situated to record all man's deeds.
So my interpretation of that is history and historians ultimately we'll put
things in their rightful place.
And so it took 50 years.
Well,
so,
uh,
I had no idea at that point when I had the speech that it,
that it was going to become a,
uh,
a,
a valuable historic document.
So when I got back home,
I put it inside of a book,
uh,
that I had from uh,
that uh,
President Harry Truman gaming.
So my senior year at Villanova,
I played in East West All star game and it was in Kansas City.
And one of the things that they did is they took us out to independence,
Missouri to meet President Truman.
So,
and when we went out to meet him,
his office at his home was a replica of the Oval Office and soy as we walked in,
each of us noticed there was two huge tables to the right with books stacked up
on them.
Well at the end after President Truman had talked with the,
with all the team and,
and the coaching staff and trainers,
he on the way out,
he gave each of us a two volume book of,
of,
of uh,
uh,
that he wrote on his presidency.
And so in the book and which I still have both of them now,
both books say,
uh,
to George Raveling from Harry s Truman best wishes and it has the date.
So I put the speech inside of one of,
those were a couple of reasons I would remember where it was in to,
I knew I'd never throw those books away because how many people can say they
have an autographed book by the President of the United States personally to
you.
So it stayed there for years and years.
And I never thought about it.
I actually,
my wife didn't even know I had cause.
And so I go to the University of Iowa's head basketball coach.
And of course I'm the first black coach during first in the big 10.
And so this,
there's much to do about this.
At that time,
all the local newspapers,
big newspapers,
had a Sunday magazine section,
uh,
on.
Uh,
and so the cover story on the Cedar Rapids Gazette paper was going to end.
This magazine section was going to be about me taking the,
the,
uh,
University of Iowa had basketball coaching job.
So as he was asking questions,
he,
what I call a throwaway question,
he said,
coach,
were you ever involved in the civil rights movement?
And I said,
well,
Kinda.
And he says,
what does that mean?
I said,
well,
I went,
I attended the march on Washington.
I was a security guard and a,
and I was able to secure that,
the speech.
And at that point,
if I've ever seen a person just physically decomposers,
I mean,
he was,
he just,
he didn't know,
he was so much more,
I couldn't figure out why it was so excited.
And so he says,
oh my God,
are you?
And he said,
where is it?
I,
I had only been there about six weeks,
so I hadn't unpacked all the boxes down in the basement.
So I said,
it's in a box down in the basement.
He said,
can we call it look for it?
And so we'd go down and not figured out what's box it was.
And I pulled it out and he was literally shaking.
And,
and so he said,
oh my God.
He said,
can I call my editor?
Can we take a picture of this?
And so I said,
sure.
So little did I,
that was the first public notice that I had to speak.
So,
so the story kind of now starts to split between rattling being the head
basketball coach unraveling have in this speech.
And so from that point on it,
it took a,
it took on a little,
uh,
a different significance,
but it's still time had not placed in,
in its rightful place.
And so over the years it became more,
and I literally,
uh,
one of the miracles,
Tim,
is that for 50 years I had this and nothing had no flood a house does it catch
on fire,
somebody that's doesn't steal a book,
whatever.
And if you saw the actual speech now have it in a vault in La for the speech to
survive this,
this long.
And,
and,
and the quality of the paper,
it's type written.
You can see little,
little typos in there and so forth.
And,
um,
I had a friend of mine who graduated with me from Villanova who was with the FBI
and,
and so one time we were talking about it and he said,
well,
if you ever get in a situation where someone doubts that,
that you really have the speech or that it was good,
he said,
we can lift the fingerprints off of there.
He said,
your fingerprints are on there and so's kings.
So it was an interesting circumstance that what became the focal part of the
speech was something they never really intended to use.
And only through the motivation of Mahalia Jackson did he ad libbed the,
the,
I have a dream piece in.
So as the years went on it,
it took on a,
a,
a unique value.
And so at one point,
my,
uh,
Turner sports does it,
a documentary on it.
And so my wife goes to work,
people are talk,
oh,
I didn't know about your husband having to speed.
So my wife comes home one evening,
she says,
Hey,
we got to have a talk.
I said,
okay.
She says,
the speech has got to get out of this house right away.
She said,
you traveled too much,
somebody's going to break in the house and,
and,
and I might get killed over to speech.
So she said,
you gotta get it Outta here.
So we put it in another ball and as naturally would happen,
uh,
various people tried to buy it from me.
But I never felt that I had total ownership of it.
I kind of felt like I was the guardian of something historic and I became so
sensitive about it that,
uh,
I stopped.
I would on black history month,
I'd get many invitations to come,
bring the speech,
talk about it.
But I,
I was so self conscious that I stopped doing it because I never wanted anybody
to think that was profiting off of this.
Uh,
an I never entertained NDT offers this to sell it.
And when I was growing up as a little boy in DC,
my grandma used to always say that money's the root of all evil.
Don't build your life around money.
And so it wasn't,
you know,
I wasn't rich,
but I wasn't poor and I wasn't desperate to make money or,
or headlines on it.
The headlines of,
of,
uh,
crude because,
of,
uh,
people's curiosity about having it.
But I,
I look back on it now and it was a classic example of being in the right place
at the right time and which has happened so much in my life.
Getting good adult advice.
If Dr. Wilson doesn't say,
Hey,
you two need to go and I'll provide the opportunity for you,
then I would have missed out on,
on a piece of,
uh,
of history that put an indelible mark on my life on incredible story.
When incredible experience,
you think about the,
how the stars aligned to happen.
And,
uh,
from that point on,
I learned a good lesson that you don't have to have a relationship with a person
for them to your,
your mentor.
And so in those days,
I,
I don't even know if I knew the connotation mentor,
but I looked at king more as,
as someone,
as a teacher,
someone that could learn from.
So as we fast forward,
and I'm now working at Nike and in my office,
I had had this picture in my office and it was a headshot of Martin Luther King,
James Baldwin in Malcolm X.
And so when people would come into my office,
they would look at the things on the wall and they would always be drawn to
that,
the portrait.
And so they,
what was interesting,
most people,
uh,
I would say 99% of the people could,
could not tell you all three of them.
A lot of people would get king,
some would get James Baldwin,
very few Malcolm X.
But,
uh,
it was rare to anyone got all three of them.
So they would ask me why I had it up there.
And I said,
uh,
they're,
they're my mentors during my inspiration.
They're the people that I,
whose lives I look to when I'm trying to figure out something complex.
And so while I didn't have a day to day relationship with,
with Dr. King,
I had a mental uh,
day to day relationship month to month,
week to week,
year to year because there was so much that I wanted to learn from him.
And one thing while it's in my mind I'd like to share with you and I don't know
if the vast majority of people that follow King Nudist,
I just found out this past week and reading a book review in The New York Times
Book Review Section that when Dr. King was in seminary at Crozier,
which is in Chester,
Pennsylvania,
that's where he,
he,
he took his practice to become a preacher a that dot.
They had a basketball team and Dr. King was on the team.
And so that,
that delighted me to no end to discover that he,
that he,
he played basketball during the time and the,
the person who wrote the book actually found in the Archives of box score from
one of their games and hunt.
Fortunately they got wax one 24 to 41.
So,
but I was so pleased to find out that there was an athletic side to him and I
don't know,
uh,
it and all that I've read about king over the years.
I had never known that he participated in athletics.
So I was there was,
uh,
an immediate joy the find out that he,
and particularly they play basketball.
And when you say you had a relationship with say,
Dr. King in the sense that you viewed him as a mentor or role model and you
revisited that,
and would you find yourself in specific situations and ask yourself,
you know,
what would Dr. King do or how did,
how did that fit in your life,
uh,
from a mentorship standpoint?
Was just putting yourself in their shoes to make hard decisions?
Or how did you think,
I think one thing that,
that,
uh,
became quickly apparent to me was that the value in and of words and,
and,
and the spoken word is such a,
a powerful tool,
perhaps,
maybe more powerful than the atom bomb in many ways.
Uh,
the fact that,
uh,
that he had a vision,
it was the whole,
I have a dream.
So all great leaders I believe,
share a vision and then they,
they then,
uh,
then they have a journey.
And so he talked about the division,
the journey,
uh,
the completion of the dream and,
and,
and the conquering of injustice.
But to me,
king was,
was so many things.
He was a preacher,
he was a messenger area visionary.
He was a,
a precursor,
a leader.
He,
he,
he was a man for all seasons and all reasons in,
in,
in many ways.
And so many times I,
I reflect back on something that he,
he said that when not when I'm in a tough spot and I think about giving up,
uh,
you said to yourself this,
what kind of sacrifices this is going to be.
And one thing I remember Dr. King saying,
there's,
if a man or a woman hasn't found something in life that they're willing to die
for,
then perhaps they're not fit to live.
And so he lives out that,
that,
that a reality that he became so deeply immersed in.
And,
and this mission that he ultimately had to give us his,
his life for it.
And I watched a number of documentaries over the years and on the sit ins and
doing the,
the depth of segregation.
And one was the night before that they were going to sit at the lunch counters.
And,
and,
uh,
the,
the person who was leading the demonstration as they were planning out at
strategically at the end,
he said to them,
he said,
I want everybody in the room to look around at each other and shake hands
because tomorrow night when we have this meeting,
some of you are not going to be here.
And I thought to myself,
oh my God,
would I have the courage of commitment to know that if I were part of this
demonstration tomorrow night,
I might get,
I have to put my life on the line.
I might not be back if I'm sitting in that room.
I have to say to myself,
are you willing to sacrifice your life for this cause?
And,
and to me,
a lot of the untold stories about segregation and,
and,
and the injustices that black people have faced most of our lives is those
people who died so that we can enjoy,
uh,
the things that we enjoy in society today.
And,
and,
uh,
so to me,
whenever I have any questions about the depth of commitment,
I go back and I say to myself,
do you feel so strong about this that you'd be willing to give your life?
What do you feel this strong about it?
That you would be willing to risk getting fired?
And,
and over the years,
especially when I was at Nike,
sometimes I had a depth of belief and conviction that what I was suggesting was
right and I was willing to fight right down to the end.
And if it meant I got fired,
then I got fired.
But I never allowed the position or to threaten me to be less than what I should
be as a person.
You mentioned your grandmother in passing and she seems to have been a very
important figure in,
in your life.
Uh,
how did that come to be the case?
Well,
my grandma was,
it was basically a,
if I can borrow a religious,
uh,
concept,
my grandmother was the pope,
her word was infallible.
And what was interesting,
my grandma's a product of a Blackfoot Indian tribe.
And on both sides of our family,
we really are,
are descendants of,
of,
of a American Indian tribes.
And which I find interesting sometime because of the,
we now I've gone through,
uh,
these,
these connotations,
uh,
when I was,
when I was a a firstborn,
which you'll find interesting.
I was born in a segregated hospital in Washington,
DC,
Garfield Hospital.
And there are four floors for whites and one for,
for black.
So,
so I came into the world and in a segregated world.
But,
um,
so as,
as,
as I was growing up,
um,
when I was nine,
my dad died and when I was 13,
my mom had a nervous breakdown and she was institutionalized the rest of her
life.
In those days,
uh,
the,
the economy was,
was in poor shape.
So you got rations from the government,
you got like flour,
sugar,
milk,
so forth.
And so I come home one day and my mom standing at the sink and she's got the
water running and she's pouring this big bag of sugar into the sink and just
letting the sugar go down.
And so I,
I grabbed it in,
turned it off,
and I,
and,
uh,
I said,
mom,
what's going on?
She wasn't,
she just,
she was incoherent.
So anyway,
my mom ended up being institutionalized.
So now here,
here's George at 13 years old and uh,
uh,
no,
I was 12 and in,
so what do you do with George?
He has no,
he has,
he has no parental supervision.
Dad's dead.
Mom's in a mental institution.
And she spent most of the rest of her life there.
And so my grandma worked for this white family and Georgetown.
And so she was sharing with the lady to house this dilemma.
And so she,
and she was sent,
I don't know,
I don't know what,
what I'm going to do,
but I have to do something for them.
And so the lady said to her daughter was,
was ahead of Catholic charities and DC and she would mention it to her.
Maybe her daughter could suit,
do something.
So Lo and behold,
the daughter decides to what she,
she's going to help.
And so she found the school,
a boarding school for me,
a Catholic boarding school in Pennsylvania was called Saint Michael's school for
boys.
It was,
and so you,
you,
uh,
she was able to get me into the school.
There.
You,
you stayed there year round as a resident.
And so I went off to St Michael's and,
uh,
the structure where priests were,
we're at,
uh,
ran the institution and the teaching and the service part.
We're done all by nuns.
And so,
uh,
over the course of the time I was there,
I did everything from Bale Hay to pick apples,
a clean chicken coops,
uh,
to work in the kitchen,
the scrub,
the floors in the chapel to make,
to make beds,
you had to do a chore to help,
uh,
offset your,
your presence there.
And so the classes were very strict and rigorous that the classes were small.
So we got a lot of individual attention and um,
it was,
it was just a stroke of,
of,
of a miracle that my grandma was able to get me into this situation.
And she,
my grandma never graduated from high school.
In fact,
no one in my family,
uh,
my mom and dad finished high school,
but she knew that there had to be a better way for me and she did everything
that she could to help me grow as a person.
I remember one one one time Tim,
my grandma took myself and my brother out and uh,
and she said,
uh,
we're going to go outside.
I want to teach you some,
some manners and lessons.
And so my,
my grandma takes him,
my brother and I out on the street and she says,
I'm going to start to teach you how to treat women.
Women are to be respected.
And so she's,
she says,
when you walked down the street,
you always walk on the outside.
A woman always walks on the inside.
When you,
when you,
when you get to the corner,
you make sure you check the traffic in both ways.
Before and then walk as more as a guard.
Uh,
if,
if a woman's getting a new car,
you always open the door for them first.
If you sit down at a table for the meal though,
you hold the cheer and help them.
And so long before feminists,
uh,
a movement was,
was even thought of,
my grandmother was teaching us social graces.
Um,
yes sir.
No,
sir.
I go on a flight now and,
and it's just part of my DNA.
Uh,
when people say some store to says something,
I say,
yes ma'am.
No ma'am,
no ma'am.
Yes sir.
No Sir.
And I'm 80 years old and I still do that.
But so,
and verbally,
what will happen on the flight is either during the flight or at the end,
the stewardess will say to me,
it,
can I ask you a question now?
Say yes,
and I know it's coming.
And they'll say,
are you,
uh,
from the military?
And I say,
well,
I was in the military,
but,
but no,
I'm not in the military now.
And,
and they said,
why are you from the south?
And I said,
no.
And so I said,
why do you ask?
And they say,
well,
because you're so polite.
No one says yes ma'am and no sir.
And I have a lot of people now who,
who find it uncomfortable.
If I say yes sir,
at 80 years old and they're younger than me,
but it's just the way I was born,
my grandma was,
was huge on manners.
And if we went somewhere,
and there were adults there in those days,
if you were a child,
kids where to be seen and not heard.
And so it,
if,
if there was a conversation going on again with the adults,
you just listen and,
but if,
if someone asks me a question and I didn't say yes ma'am and no ma'am,
when I got home,
my grandma would say,
I heard Mr. Jenkins asked you that and you,
you,
you just said yeah.
And she said,
Ben Dover and she,
she whipped me.
And so,
and my greatest quote for my grandma was,
she told me one time,
she said,
there's more horses asses in the world and there are horses now.
That's all.
That's been my favorite grandma.
She's a good teacher and good enforcer.
Well,
were there any other mentors during that or teachers or people who had a strong
impact on you over that stay in that Catholic school?
Yeah,
it was sister that was a nun who took a liking to me,
named sister Dolores.
She,
she lived to be 87,
but she,
she,
for some reason,
she saw something in me I never saw in myself.
And she would always say positive things to me.
At the time I didn't realize the value of them,
but she'd always say to me,
George,
you can be special.
Or,
uh,
or if I wasn't working up to my potential in whatever area it was,
she would say,
and that's not being special and you were,
you,
you're on earth to be special and night to me.
I'd never had anybody look at me and,
and,
and make me think I could be anything other than,
than average.
But she,
she constantly preached that to me and she would watch the basketball games and,
and,
and after she would come up,
or the next day in class,
she would say,
well,
you know,
in the third quarter,
you,
you really,
you really were loafing out there.
But she always found a way to,
to,
uh,
I write a paper and she'd read it and she'd say,
this is really good,
but this is not your best stuff.
You can do better than.
So she always kind of created this contest of,
uh,
having me compete,
compete against myself.
It was never competing against the other students as always me competing against
myself.
So she,
she taught me that the power of,
of,
of positive have a positive attitude and she would never allow me to think
negatively.
And then the other person was my college.
Oh,
was my high school coach.
Uh,
he taught me so many lessons about life at our school.
They were forced sports,
boxing,
baseball,
basketball,
and football.
And so one of the things that you learned,
if you wanted to get off campus,
some you,
you,
you participate in sports.
And so I actually participated in every one and the one that probably gets a
zero attention because a lot of people just don't know what's boxing.
I actually box golden glove really years.
Yeah.
I,
I know you were Chinese foot boxing so you can probably identify with that,
but I wouldn't want to deal with your reach.
And so I actually,
somewhere in one of my high school scrapbooks,
I have a picture of me and a ring in those days you wear the head gear and he
had a big laugh,
big gloves.
And so I fought in my weight class.
Oh,
it's at that time I wish I was a under 200 pounds now.
But,
uh,
so I,
I actually won my,
my senior year I won the golden glove event.
And so,
uh,
and then I played baseball.
I played first base and pitched and in football I played in all except the last
year.
And then,
uh,
we didn't have a good quarterback.
So my coach put me at quarterback,
but I was,
believe me,
uh,
the,
my talents word,
I wouldn't even have gotten a walk on offer,
but I was the quarterback.
And then what happened was basketball between my eighth grade year and ninth
grade year,
I grew four inches.
So I went from six foot to six,
four and one year.
And so obviously the height advantage prove beneficial to me early on in
basketball.
And so over the course of the four years,
I got better and better and land looked back on it.
Now a lot of it was sistered the Lorac encourage me,
kept telling me,
Oh,
you're getting better,
or,
and,
and you.
And so she kept me motivated all the time.
So my senior year I ended up being the second leading scorer in the state of
Pennsylvania.
And,
um,
so at this point,
uh,
let's just step back real quick.
So at the end of my junior year,
I'm waiting.
I'm waiting for to take the Greyhound bus back to DC for,
I get a week vacation back in DC.
So I'm sitting there waiting for the bus to come by.
And Tim,
I can remember,
it was like yesterday,
I thought to myself,
God,
if I can just graduate and become a pilot in the air force,
I'll have it made.
I had no idea anything about basketball was going to take me and get me a
scholarship.
So the following year I ended up the second leading scorer in the state.
And so we're playing at saint rose in Carbondale.
And after the game,
when I come out of the locker room,
a gentleman comes up to me and he says,
hi,
my name's Jack Ramsey.
I'm the coach at at Saint Joe College.
And he hands me a a card of course,
Jack Ramsey in his,
in the basketball hall of fame.
Great coach.
And so he said that I like the way you play,
we'd like to offer you a scholarship.
And I said,
yes sir.
Every time he'd say something,
I just say yes sir.
Cause I didn't know what else to say.
And so on the school bus ride back to the school,
my,
uh,
coach says,
who's that man you're talking to outside the locker room?
And I said he was a coach and I hand them to the card.
And so my coaches,
well,
what did he tell you?
And I said,
he said that he wanted to offer me a scholarship.
And so I said,
coach,
what's the scholarship?
Because I had no idea what that you could,
that they would pay for your education and return you participated in
basketball.
So then by over the course of the remainders season,
I had an offer from a Michigan state,
Villanova and uh,
and Gettysburg and a bunch of those schools.
But I add Gettysburg because their coach did the best job of recruiting me.
He'd write me hand written letters,
four and five pages on what it was going to mean to go to Gettysburg and so
forth.
He drive up to games.
He was so persistent.
But at the end of the day to reality was just as far as the nuns and the priests
were concern would,
it would've been,
it would've been heresy to go to,
to a state institution.
I was going to a Catholic school.
So then it basically came down to Saint Joseph,
Villanova and I went down for the visit and vote at Villanova and why I was
there.
They gave me admissions exam.
He didn't have PSA and act then.
And so I took the admissions exam the first day I was there.
And once again,
amazing insight by sister Delores sheet.
When she found out I was going to get scholarships offers,
she started to make me stay after school every day and work on,
on the entrance exams.
So,
uh,
so I was prepared and,
and I,
and so the Sunday before we left the drive back up to hope and heights,
uh,
the coach Al severance offered me a scholarship and,
and the,
we wanted to decision why we were there.
So basically my,
my high school coach made the decision.
He thought that that's where I should go.
And,
and,
uh,
little did I know that,
that basketball was going to be this transformative force in my life that was
going to take me someplace.
I'd never thought that I could go,
Tim never in my life.
And I don't mean this in a mean spirited way.
Did anyone in my family ever say to me,
George,
when you grow up,
I want you to go to college.
It was,
date was no reason for them to think that
at that time it was a,
uh,
it wasn't,
it wasn't even a dream or our thought because nobody had had received that type
of education and go back to my grandma's.
So I call my grandma and I tell her what's going on and then I'm going to get
this scholarship.
And so I,
I tell her,
uh,
well,
how does it work?
I said,
okay,
so if I agree to play on the basketball team for the four years,
they'll,
they'll pay for my education.
So my Gr,
so all of a sudden there's utter silence on the phone.
And I said,
grandma,
are you still there?
And she said,
yes.
I said,
why you so quiet?
She says,
oh,
I just feel like a failure.
I said,
well,
what do you mean?
And she said,
I thought I raised you better than that.
And I said,
well,
grandma,
what did I do wrong?
And she said,
stupid.
Don't white people going,
going to give you a free education to play basketball?
You,
how can you go?
How could you be so stupid to believe she could not comprehend that?
That because of the racial situation that someone would pay for your education
and all you had to do was play basketball.
And she,
she just,
it took her over a year before she fully was able to even trust that this was
when I finally got on campus at Villanova and went to the first class then.
Then she,
she kind of started to,
to be a lot more trustful of the process.
But,
uh,
it was,
I look back on it now and it just shows you the depth and of a stain of,
of racism and how things are,
uh,
are implanted in your mind that you just,
you just can't there in comprehensible.
So on that,
on that note,
when I was doing homework,
I read somewhere that you have a collection of racist,
momentous,
yes.
How you did do some research.
Could you I,
beyond that,
I don't know the details,
but that just stuck in my mind and cause that's something I think that a lot of
people would actively avoid.
So why do you have this collection?
Well,
first of all,
I,
uh,
you know,
no one's ever asked me that question,
but I spent,
I probably have over $100,000 worth of black collectibles for about eight or
nine years.
It became an obsession with me.
And so I would go to antique shows and,
and,
and go to stores and hunt down all black memorabilia.
I have things that date back before I actually have a first edition or uncle
Tom's cabin.
So I started to collect books,
fingerings,
and postcards,
postcards that was started with finger rings.
And so I,
um,
I,
I've,
a friend of mine told me about a,
um,
an antique store that was closing and the gentleman had a huge collection of
black collectibles.
And so it was in San Pedro.
So I went down and I,
and I paid him $35,000 for the collectables.
He had a war,
a hundred pieces.
And part of the deal was that he had the mark and write a little card.
So I understand the historic significance of postcards.
Tim,
I have him back before you had,
which this might surprise you that originally that you didn't have to put a
stamp on,
on a postcard to send it out to mail.
So I have,
I have them back in.
The earliest one I have is,
is 1891.
Wow.
But what was interesting about the black postcards was they always made blacks,
uh,
they pictured him in a derogatory term.
One of the more frequent ones you see is a black person with,
uh,
eating watermelon with a smile on his face.
Um,
but there were all derogatory.
Now here's what's further interesting on we've now,
um,
you put stamps on them.
So I was able to read the messages on some of them.
And,
and,
uh,
and so the one that I remembered the most is a ladies right into one of her
girlfriends and we'll just make up the name.
She says,
Helen,
we have a Nigga that works at our house that smells just like him.
And so in those days,
to use the word nigger was commonplace.
Uh,
uh,
and you just,
I don't know that you ever learn to accept it,
but it w it was something that was said commonplace.
So I started to build this historic collection of,
of,
of memorabilia so that I could have a legacy for my children and their children
and I could,
I have them on display at my home to remind me of,
uh,
of,
of where we were and where we are today and,
and the trials and tribulations that we've gone through.
So I easily have postcards.
I,
I probably have over 300 and postcards and I probably have about 500 of the,
uh,
figurines.
I was just thinking me,
cause I have some,
I have some original Angia Mama,
uh,
flower part,
packs.
And that I,
once I got going,
it was amazing that things that I was able to,
to collect.
And um,
so I had so many of them that I couldn't put them all on display.
So I have probably three quarters of them are boxed up in storage,
but,
and then the others are,
are,
are around my house.
Do you collect anything else or have you collected anything else?
Uh,
books and friends.
I,
uh,
in my library at home I have well over 2,500 books and probably have another,
six or 700 [inaudible] that are,
that are in storage because it just ran out of a space.
But I,
I just couldn't tenue to,
uh,
buy books to read them.
I have as you probably research,
I have an unusual way of going about reading books,
but,
uh,
and,
and friends,
I don't have a strategy or anything for a friend's that most times people when I
meet them or not,
who they ended up being,
whether it was Phil Knight,
Bob Knight,
John Thompson,
Sonny Vaccaro,
I could tell you tons of people when I met him,
they were not who they ended up being.
But for some reason we were able to build an authentic and sustainable
relationship.
And I've always looked upon relationships as a privileged,
uh,
that you and,
and you,
at the end of the day,
at the core of all relationships in my mind is trust and respect.
And so both of those have to be earned.
And so over the years,
uh,
I've met people and unintentionally we've stayed in touch and there's been this
level of trust that,
uh,
that's allowed to the,
the relationship to endure.
But it's something that slot like marriage.
You have to work at it.
You have to,
to,
to understand that there's a balance in relationships.
And with me,
I,
I'm the number one thing that I asked myself continually is what can I do for,
for you?
And,
uh,
your,
your good friend Ryan holiday.
And I had dinner last night and one of the very last things I said to him,
I said,
Ryan,
is there anything I can be doing for you in the next 30 days?
I've always had this theory that if you help enough people get what they want,
you'll always get what you want.
And so I've never tried to enter a relationship based on selfish mode,
is that if I notice person,
I'm going to get these benefits.
I saw,
I tried to find out what do we have in common as people,
what is it that we can share?
How can I help this person no matter how famous they are or how successful they
are,
everyone has certain needs even if they're just psychological needs or,
or we all need truth tellers in our life.
And so,
um,
and building relationships,
I try to make sure that I surround myself with people who,
who want to see me become better and can help me become better,
that I can learn from them and,
and then I can contribute to their lives.
And so,
um,
most of the,
the friendships I have in life,
they,
they all started by,
by mistake.
Uh,
you wanted a young men that,
that's here today,
uh,
that is taught me almost all I know about technology.
I spoke at a clinic and,
and,
and Orlando and I,
so,
uh,
a friend of mine,
Kevin Eastman was running the clinic and,
uh,
I said to him,
I said,
who's going to,
who's going to put my presentation up on the screen in that?
Do you have a it guy?
And he said,
yes.
And so,
so I said,
well,
introduce him to me because I want put my presentation up.
I went to walk to the back of the room and make sure it's clear and so forth.
So,
so,
uh,
I met Alex of Rca and,
and,
uh,
during the time I was there,
we just hit it off.
And so when he,
I,
I'm pretty sure he was taking me back to the airport and I asked him if he,
if he would be interested in doing a website for me.
And he said yes.
And so that's how it started.
And it's turned into a lifelong friendship.
And,
um,
and I think that was the start of me recognizing that I needed to be around more
young people.
And so I,
I don't associate,
and I,
maybe it's bad to say this,
but I don't hang out with many people my own age.
Most of the people that I associate with are our younger people because I think
they're the future.
They're smart.
They're naive enough that they'll tell you the truth and,
and,
uh,
and they're not afraid to tell you if they think you're wrong.
And when I hang around people my own age,
it tends to always revert back to the past.
And,
and so,
and I don't want to talk about coaching at Washington state of being the first
black this or the first black.
That what I want to do is,
is figure out at 80 years old,
what is it that I don't know,
but need to know and how is this going to help me stay relevant in this ever
changing world?
And so I've tend to spend most of my time with younger people who inspire me,
who,
who I can,
uh,
and have,
a partnership with.
That's the other thing about relationships.
I think relationships at their most authentic stage.
It,
it's a partnership.
It's,
it's,
uh,
we,
we share,
we share common vision,
common goals,
common objectives,
common strategy,
common execution plan.
It's a we mentality.
It's not a me went out mentality and it's a win win mentality.
It's not I win,
you lose or you lose.
I win.
It's not about that.
We would,
we were in this thing together and we're in the boat together.
We're going to row in the same direction and we're going to take,
get the boat ashore.
You mentioned books and uh,
I want to make sure we give reading at least a few minutes because you are known
as a voracious reader,
the human Google one nickname,
and you've read probably,
I'm sure,
thousands of books at this point.
Uh,
you were very kind when we first got here where we're recording this right now.
You said,
I learned from the,
uh,
the wise men.
It's always a good thing to bear gifts or something along those lines.
And you gave me several books.
He's also gifted many,
many different books.
Uh,
how did this love affair with books start?
And could you tell us about how you read books?
Because as you alluded to earlier,
you have a particular way of reading books.
Well,
as I look back on it now,
Tim,
uh,
and the point of references so many times as we speak,
is always going to be my grandma.
Well,
my grandma told me one time,
she used to s when she'd be in the Kitchen Cook and she tells me stories.
And one time my grandma told me,
she said,
George,
you know,
back in the days of slavery to plantation owners use to,
to put their money in books and,
and,
and hide them up on this,
put them up on the bookshelves as because of their banking system,
wasn't as sophisticated as it is today.
And so I said,
well,
grandma,
why,
why did they do that?
And she said,
because they didn't have to worry about the slave stealing the money because the
slaves would never take the books off the shelf because they couldn't read.
And so from that,
I began to understand that as long as someone can control your mind,
they can control who you are in your body.
And so I,
I decided that I was never going to allow myself to be in a position where,
uh,
someone can cook,
control my mind and control my body because of my lack of information and
knowledge.
And,
and so I decided that I was going to try to reheat and learn as much as I
possibly could on a continual basis because I,
I believe that,
uh,
people will have a greater respect for you if,
if they respect you and electrically,
and I've often felt in life if,
if I had the choice between Tim Liking me or Tim respected me,
I'd far more hope that,
that you respect me then like me and I figured the byproduct of you respected me
will be that you'll,
you'll learn to like me.
So I don't work at trying to get people to like me.
So I've,
I've been on this mission for,
for a reading for years and years and years and it's become an obsession now
with me.
I,
I don't go anywhere without a book and a notebook.
And so if I'm,
if I'm in line,
if I go to a doctor's office,
like take a book with me.
If I'm in the,
I have a new system now,
if I go to a bookstore and I'm,
and Barnes and noble and align has got eight or nine people in it,
rather than stand there,
uh,
for 10 minutes waiting,
I start,
I'll start reading the book right there in line and start underlining things.
And,
uh,
so I have all these quirks that I've acquired over the years with reading books.
First of all,
um,
I divide the book into messages.
I don't think,
I don't spend any time now trying to read a whole book because there's probably
most books,
there's probably maybe eight to 10 chapters that are really powerful and
influential.
Uh,
and,
and the others I skimmed through.
So I never start a book from the front and,
and,
and go to the back.
I just go,
I'll open the index and I'll find what I believe is an interesting chapter.
And I start there.
And that's actually how I purchase a book.
When I'm in the bookstore,
I have this routine that I go through that and,
and,
and if the,
if passes,
I buy the book.
And if it doesn't,
I don't buy the book.
And uh,
what's your routine?
So,
so if I,
let's say I'm going to envision this one.
So our officers as an Elsa Gundo,
which is a s a s outside of Los Angeles and,
and so I go to a Barnes and noble layer.
One thing I found out that because there's so many corporate offices within a
two mile radius that they tend to house a really excellent,
uh,
business books.
So I'll go in and soon as I go in,
I go,
I look at the books that are on reduction sale to see if there's some something
there that might be a good buy.
Then I go to the new roof,
new releases,
nonfiction.
And uh,
by the way,
I go to,
I go to a bookstore four to five days out of the week.
I'm constantly going in and I just call it search and discovery.
So I'll go to new releases in a nonfiction and I'll look through the books and
there's usually 20 books on the table.
I'd say eight out of 10 times,
I'm going to find a book that,
that I had never heard of before.
And so I'll pick the book up,
I go to the back,
I read about the author,
and then I go to the front part and I read the promos down this side.
And then the next thing I do is I go to the,
uh,
the chapters and I find a chapter and I'll open it up and I'll see,
it,
uh,
the writer's style,
I look at the style.
Is this someone that says a book filled with a lot of statistics or stories
because I know what I'm looking for.
The books that I've have had the most impact are the ones that make me change
the way I think or act or behave.
Uh,
and uh,
those are the books that ultimately end up being the best for me.
So I'll go through the book,
Eh,
and then once I find this one chapter,
I start to read some of it and now,
and I can tell if this is going to be me or not.
And at that point,
uh,
I'll purchase the book,
but I just don't go in and buy a book based on,
on the top 10.
Not that there's anything wrong with that,
it's just that I've had better success.
And then,
uh,
so now here at 80 years old,
two of my favorite authors are Ryan holiday and Walter Isaacson.
Uh,
they've both taken me on interesting and intellectual Jew journeys.
The first book I read by Walter Isaacson was Steve Jobs.
And,
uh,
I was so blown away.
I had underlined about three quarters of the book.
I was quoting,
writing down quotes.
And as you notice,
Steve Jobs book couldn't be anything you want it to be.
It can be a thesis on leadership.
It was just utterly fascinating.
I'd loved Walter Isaacson's writing style.
So when I finished the book,
I looked,
I went back,
I said,
damn,
I liked the way that he writes.
So I go back and I looked to see what else he had written.
And so I didn't,
I see he's on a book on Benjamin Franklin.
He's done a book on,
uh,
on Einstein.
So at the,
and subsequently Kissinger and others.
Uh,
so I,
I go to the bookstore and I buy the Benjamin Franklin book and I am blown away
and a little sad because I feel like God damn,
I went to all his education.
No one ever taught me any of this stuff other than the kite.
Uh,
and so before that,
I think if you'd ask me who was the most important American of all time,
I think I would have probably tended to say Abraham Lincoln.
But after I read Isaacson's book on Benjamin Franklin,
there was a,
I would now feel,
I mean,
you know,
it's a lottery system that,
uh,
the banking schools,
streets,
uh,
the guy,
he did so many unbelievable things.
And then from there I went to,
to,
uh,
Einstein and anybody who can write a book on Einstein debt,
an idiot like me can understand the,
the,
uh,
physics.
And,
and it was,
it was absolutely,
uh,
it was a miracle.
So in the book,
Tim,
I Read,
uh,
that Einstein was very active in what they would capture in those times as the
Negro movement.
And it says that he wrote a book on Einstein in a Negro movement.
Well,
I had never heard of this.
So I immediately stop reading and go Google Einstein on the Negro problem.
And Lo and behold,
it comes up.
So I,
I chased the book down.
And,
um,
so what I find that a lot of times in reading books and is a in,
in,
in your book,
tools of the Titan.
I'm reading and I,
and I see this you mentioned in there about masterminds,
and I had never heard of mastermind.
So I,
I a circle it and I write Google behind it.
So I go back and I go online and I,
and I,
uh,
and I find out loud.
So I'm thinking to myself,
oh my God,
how do you did,
I didn't ever knew about this.
So how do I,
how do I become part of it?
So I sent some information to Ryan holiday about,
about this mastermind.
So he gets back to me,
he says,
Oh,
I'm surprised you didn't know about that.
He says,
you want to go?
I'll get you in.
So the next thing I know,
I get this invite to go to two masterminds and Carmel Valley and,
and my eight years on earth,
that was the greatest collection of intellects that I'd ever been around in my,
in my life.
I was so intimidated.
And what was marvelous.
That was when I knew I was on the right path because every,
I'm 80 years old,
the next oldest person there is probably 49.
They're all young,
energetic people.
And I,
I was,
uh,
readily admit,
I was so intimidated.
I didn't think I was thinking to myself,
God,
how am I going to fit in?
And every night I went to bed with the worst headaches that ever had.
Cause I was,
I couldn't process all this stuff.
I felt,
I thought his second day I've already filled up a notebook of notes.
And,
um,
it was one of those life changing experiences.
So you,
you helped me,
uh,
grow as a person just by what you mentioned in,
in,
in tools to the titan.
We'll thank you for reading it,
first of all.
And,
uh,
this is,
I'm,
I'm sure that,
uh,
with all my notes here today,
I'm going to have to figure out a way to have another conversation with you for
sure.
So I hope,
hopefully I won't blow it between now and the end of the interview,
but,
uh,
books that you've re-read the most yourself or gifted to other people the most,
are there any books that come to mind?
Well,
I,
you know,
being 80 years old,
it's a long span of,
of,
uh,
reading,
to books that I've given out the most.
Uh,
rarely do I,
I mean,
I go to meet anyone and I don't,
I can't tell you the last time I met someone and I didn't bring him a book.
It's just become a habit now to bring the,
give them a book.
In most cases,
I'd give them two or three books.
But the books that I've given away the most lately are,
uh,
Ryan's two books,
opts,
uh,
obstacles and ego is the enemy and a 12 rules for life by Jordan Peterson who,
I actually,
that this was one where I happen to go into Barnes and noble.
The data book arrives and I go through it and it gets passed as my test.
And so I get back to the,
to the hotel and I started reading a book.
And before I know it's 2:00 AM in the morning and I'm still,
I'm,
the guys got me hooked already.
And so I started telling people,
uh,
all you got to get this book out and no one's ever heard his guy.
Although,
and Ken and I understand he's quite controversial.
He teaches,
he's a professor at the University of Toronto.
So then about three weeks go by and all of a sudden as an explosion,
it's now number two on the best sellers and so forth.
So I would say I probably have given away somewhere between 20 and 30 copies of
that to friends.
A S A s I'll get a note from someone every now and then saying,
hey,
tell me a good book to read that that's the one I recommend the most.
Uh,
I give Tim's,
uh,
I mean Ryan's books away a lot.
One thing that I like about Ryan's book,
it's,
it's easier to see the carry cause it's smaller.
So I can,
I can get a little,
uh,
a bag and I can put 12 of them in there.
Mine are not as user friendly from caring perspective.
No,
but,
but that's,
that's the one thing I found.
What your two books is,
it's,
uh,
I take them on as a personal challenge.
I said,
if he,
he spent this much time with this many pages,
I am not going to allow to the length of the book to intimidate me.
I'm going to see this as an opportunity.
And so,
uh,
you,
what,
what I did with tools of the Titan was I call that my China book.
So,
uh,
it's,
it's 13 hours to Shanghai or 13 hours to Hong Kong.
13 coming back as 26 hours a minute.
So I can,
I can,
I can knock,
knock that sucker out.
I just some books you just have to find the right environment in which to read
them.
Totally.
So I'm going to actually
just pause for a minute.
We'll keep the recording going.
I'm going to go grab the books that you brought from me cause I'd love to talk
about those.
I'll be right back.
Okay.
So here we have five bucks and I'll just read off the titles quickly and then
uh,
I'd love to hear you explain your reasons for choosing a few of these perhaps.
So the first is life is so good,
George Dawson and Richard Globin.
The next is the true believer,
subtitle,
thoughts on the nature of mass movements by Eric Hoffer.
Next we have blue highways by William least heat,
Moon,
that's quite a name.
Then we have whiplash.
How to survive are faster future Joi Ito and Jeff,
how actually no joy.
I have not read this book though.
So she put it on.
They enjoy the now they could assign a truth.
Hector Mcdonald's.
Uh,
I would love to hear you explain why you like,
or why you chose perhaps a few of these.
I think.
Well,
my first goal was,
uh,
as I said to you when I first entered the room is that,
the,
what I learned from the three wise men was they always came bearing gifts.
And so I felt that,
uh,
that I wanted to share something with you as you wish of values as you were
sharing something with me of value and allow me to be on your program.
So I thought long and hard about the types of books that,
uh,
a Princeton graduate who would find interesting.
And so I went back through and I,
and I,
uh,
the first one is life is so good is about,
about a black young man who was a slave.
And that 98 years old,
he decides that he's going to teach himself to right.
Wow.
And then he subsequently goes back and gets his GED.
And,
uh,
it's a fascinating story about that.
He never allowed his environment to,
to imprison him.
He,
it,
it took them a while to realize that,
that he had the capabilities to still re.
But what was more important was that he wanted to do it.
And so he,
he taught himself to Rady,
ended up going back to school.
And now one of the things in here was a,
they have a couple of letters that young kids who read the book.
And,
and so here's a cute,
when it says,
dear Mr. Dawson,
I'm in second grade,
I live in Wisconsin.
I'm glad that your brain still works.
Happy 10th anniversary.
And then the one other one it says,
I'm happy that you can read now.
I'm glad you liked school.
I do too.
I'm in the fourth grade.
Your friend Alex.
So it just,
and uh,
this is to me is one of the true classics of all time.
This is a,
the true believer by Eric Coffer.
Coffer was a longshoreman in San Francisco.
He's self educated and in this book is about,
uh,
about,
fanatics and how the people become so engrossed in mass movements.
A lot of the backdrop for his rationale has to do with Hitler's rise to power in
Germany.
Uh,
and,
uh,
this,
I just want to remember,
I'm pretty sure the book came out in,
in 1951.
He wrote this.
And so it's every bit as a contemporary as in fact,
if there was one of these books that I would say that you should,
someone should pick up and read right now.
I would say it's so applicable,
even though it was written in 51,
uh,
on,
is this the true believer by Eric Hoffer?
I don't think you can get it in hardback now,
but it's a marvelous book.
Blue High Waist is,
uh,
was one that I read twice.
And a William lease heat moon was the professor at,
uh,
an and English at the University of Missouri.
And he arrived at a point where he was totally bored at being the professor,
and he makes a,
uh,
a unique decision to abandon his career,
sell everything he has.
Yeah.
He has a,
a credit card.
He sells everything he has and he decides that he's gonna,
he's gonna travel the blue highways of life and he's going to go all around the
America and all he's going to do is going to small towns off of blue highways
and,
and take up residence there for a day,
two a week,
and just talk to the local inhabitants and going to restaurants and,
and learn other people's stories and,
and,
and the challenges and successes.
And so the,
the blue highway connotation,
uh,
and I noticed because I taught math reading when I was in the army is the,
the,
the on a map.
The blue highways are our secondary therapy and,
and,
uh,
as the,
the major highways that are drawn in red.
And so he decided that I don't want to travel around America on the main
highways of life because the real stories are off the blue highways.
And it,
it's just an incredible story,
uh,
of,
of his journey.
And it gives you a look at,
at,
uh,
America,
from a,
a perspective that you,
you would normally,
uh,
and what you find out,
even in these little towns around America,
there's not a whole lot of different people.
They,
they,
they have their anxiety,
does,
they have their joys,
they have the revisions.
But one thing I noticed was that people in the smaller towns tend to lead a much
simpler life and,
and uh,
and their values are,
are,
are lot more sustainable.
And what I mean by that,
they're the,
they have fixed values that they've grown up with from a child and they've never
compromised.
It's a great book.
I,
uh,
once again,
I spend a good bit of time trying to figure out which ones I thought you would
like.
The,
the,
the actual next one is I bought at the University of Penn Bookstore,
uh,
about five months ago.
I never go to Philadelphia and don't go to the pin bookstore and,
and they have an incredible collection of books.
And so at that time I was thinking to myself,
you know,
you need to change the,
the subjects matter a little bit.
The dominant conversation is Marcus,
is the future to future,
get to the future first,
what's the future going to be look like?
And so I started to realize,
you know,
you need to understand more about what it is,
the future and what it is and what the potential.
So I'm,
as I'm going through going to the bookstore,
I decide only books,
I'm going to buy our books that talk about the future.
So I ended up buying about six books.
And so I came across this as,
as the good Lord,
help me discover this book and it's called whiplash.
How to survive our,
uh,
are faster future.
And it's written by two professors at Mit.
And the book is,
is,
is incredible.
And as you can I ideas,
drawing books.
You have a lot of underlines.
Do you mind if I take a quick look at it?
No,
no,
no.
I just want to,
I'm a bit of a note taking fanatics.
So always fascinated to see how people take notes.
So you have underlines,
you have things that are circled and I see Google here.
Then you have something that is circled and looks like it has spines around it.
It's like almost like a cactus.
So is that a,
what do you reserve that for the ones which circle are,
I'm always looking for way new ways to explain things and to teach.
So those are words that I'll go back and I'll transfer into one of my journals
because I'm looking for new ways to explain things.
Sometimes a person will be mentioned and I,
and so I'll circle that.
I'll,
I'll write those down.
So every day I take about a half an hour on Google at Google People's names.
I Google as I,
as I said,
with masterminds.
And then I,
uh,
I'll have where you see the markings on the side of a paragraph.
That means when I go back that I want to reread that in its entirety.
And it's really in this market right here,
but it looks like just to,
for people who are listening to this,
it's basically a bunch of horizontal lines stacked,
uh,
in the margin from the beginning of say this paragraph to the bottom of the
paragraph.
So that's something that you will reread and make comments.
Like on this paragraph I wrote on unbelievable,
uh,
this was a quote that I wanted to,
to put it in my journal on quotes.
And,
and so this was a person that was mentioned that I want to,
I want,
I want a Google.
A lot of times what will happen,
Tim,
I go back and I Google a person and,
and uh,
and,
and then immediately I go to see if they have a Twitter account.
And if they do,
then I,
then I sign up for the Twitter account.
And so to me,
the handheld device has become my own personal library and my source of
information.
But we're,
we're,
uh,
I've discovered a growing problem is,
is there's this huge proliferation of information today.
We were overwhelmed with information.
Uh,
and so what I find out is that it,
for me,
I have to ha have to segment the information.
So I have this little formula,
inflammation equals knowledge,
knowledge equals wisdom,
wisdom and equals growth.
Growth,
growth allows me to share.
So,
so I take the,
the,
the information and I segment an end to magazine reading blogs,
articles and books.
And what I found out,
uh,
is that I was devoting an inordinate amount of time to blogs,
articles and magazines and newspapers and,
and,
and it was,
it was compromising my book reading.
So what I had to do was to start to plan out my week.
And so I'll have,
I'll have a day where I say,
uh,
blogs,
magazines and newspapers,
and then I'll have a day where as book day.
So that day,
um,
I,
I'm not doing anything but reading,
reading my books,
the other,
what thing I have to do is try to figure out other ways to get book reading in.
So if I,
if I,
uh,
hop on a flight from La to,
to Austin,
I,
I put four books in and my book bag that I carry on the plane and I read four
books at a time.
I have a lot of crazy things they do.
For example,
this is one of them.
Yes.
Uh,
so just for people wondering is,
I love how wide ranging this is.
The mind is the title.
It's projections and multiple facets by Yogi budge on Phd,
master of Kundalini Yoga with grew churn,
s Calsa Phd.
Amazing.
So,
so what I do is if I get bored when I'm reading a,
I'll just switch to another book or a,
know it until I get one that really captures my attention.
So when I get on the plane,
I'm going to,
I usually start off by reading the Wall Street in New York Times in the local
paper,
and then by the second half I'll go to my books.
And so I,
I,
like I said,
I just have all these crazy things.
So,
for example,
uh,
I've,
I've trained myself to understand that the,
the blank pages,
I'd made all of the blank pages in a book.
Uh,
a valuable cause.
I take every blank page and I write and I write a notes in there so I don't have
to,
to switch to my notebook real,
some more handy.
So as you can see under a lot of the blank pages and you're running on AI,
right?
And,
and,
and as I,
I,
I go or I skip around.
Wow.
So hold on,
said,
and this spread,
you have three different highlighters.
You have,
I suppose,
pink,
yellow,
and green.
And do you have some red emphasis at the top of that particular page?
Well,
what,
what I,
what I do is it helps redirect my attention,
uh,
to what's important.
If,
if I,
uh,
if you saw a speech that I gave,
for example,
I was the graduation speaker a couple of years ago at Villanova,
and if you saw the,
the speech,
it's a,
it's,
it's just amaze of colors and I,
my brain is trained that the,
the colors we'll,
we'll,
we'll redirect my attention.
And so if it's all pink,
that in many ways it really wasn't any sense to underline it.
I mean to,
to color it.
So I,
I tend to go back once I read this a book,
I go back now and I'll,
I'll,
I'll reread the book and,
and,
and go with the underlining again.
And sometimes if it's really powerful enough,
I just do it right then.
So on the,
the key phrases or words that you circle,
so my system is,
I put he h and the margin next to it,
which stands for phrase.
And then on the very beginning of the book,
I created an index of phrases.
So I'll have ph and then I'll put in the,
the book numbers.
And,
uh,
similarly you do these multiple passes.
So on all go through a book and I'll underline or highlight and then I'll go
through it a second time.
And the margin I'll put t two and a circle around it just for Tim to like second
pass for things I find really interesting.
And then if I read it a third time,
I'll go through and I'll do T3 and so I can,
I can not only see what was interesting me,
interesting to me at different times,
but also sometimes I'll get so excited reading a book.
I don't know if you'd do this,
but I'll,
I'll highlight so much of like,
okay,
well I might as well have not highlighted anything cause I highlighted
everything.
And uh,
then the second time around I'll be a little bit more,
uh,
precise maybe.
And uh,
so then I can go and I have my own table
of contents,
which it looks like is similar to what you do.
Yeah.
What I found out is in reading books now is when I go back on the second passage
of the book or reading it,
I find,
uh,
some pages that were,
where I didn't have anything underlying.
And so just my inquisitive self,
I'll go back and read that page and be three or four things that,
that,
that I want to underline or are one to ponder.
Ron and I and I can understand,
wow,
how did I miss this?
So the second reading for me is,
is revealing because I always find something that I missed that maybe my brain
just was,
uh,
was,
was functioning too fast or I was being distracted.
And so,
uh,
I've learned that as a second reading is,
is,
is vitally important.
And so then the last thing I would do is I would end up transferring these two
journals and I actually have book notes back to 1972 is when I started to,
to keep them in three ring binders.
And what I would do is when I was done with a book,
I would just give the book to my,
uh,
those days it was secretary.
So I'd give it to my secretary and she would type out everything that I had
underlined in the book.
And then she created a cover page for it.
And so I have a three ring binders.
I probably have 12 or 15 from Washington state and I probably have,
I only stayed at Iowa for years,
but I'd say I probably have about eight from,
uh,
um,
Iowa and,
and probably maybe 15 or 20 from USC.
So I actually have,
um,
uh,
the,
my,
uh,
saved my notes over the years and one thing that they've been a great source of,
of not only learning and reflection,
but I,
I can,
I find information that I can utilize in speeches.
And it's,
it's interesting also when you look back in the,
I think people,
uh,
50 years ago placed a greater importance on,
on,
on writing skills and word usage isn't,
it was it was an art form now.
And,
and,
and how people go about explaining themselves is,
uh,
but most of the books I read,
I,
uh,
there are very few of them that I don't come away and feel that I'm a better
person.
One of the things I like to ask myself at the close of every day is,
what did I do to make myself a better person than I was yesterday?
What did I learn today?
And,
and so,
uh,
from a talk that I do,
I say to every day is composed of 86,400 seconds of opportunities and how
shameful as it for me to at the close of my day to say that I didn't do anything
today to make myself a better person than I was yesterday,
then that's shame on me because I had 86,400 seconds of opportunities that do
something.
Even if it's no more than that,
then a thank you or random smile,
a pat on the back.
Think about this,
Tim.
There are a lot of people in this country who go through 24 hours and never have
anyone say anything to him positive.
You might be the only person that day who said something to that person that was
positive or I know we're in a different culture now and I always think I'm
running a little risk,
but if I'm in a restaurant or somewhere and I didn't see and and in a person's
waiting on me and he or she has a great smile,
I invariably say,
hey,
you have a great smile.
I,
I sometimes I feel a little uneasy when I say it to a female because I don't
want,
you know,
someone might think of trying to come onto him,
but at the same time I'm willing to take that risk.
So earlier when we were leaving breakfast,
uh,
as we were leaving,
the two waitresses said,
thanks for coming.
And they had a big smile on their face.
So I said to both of them,
both you,
two of you have a great smile.
Well,
to me,
I like practicing random acts of kindness because so much today we're were cruel
and unintentionally cruel,
but we,
we,
we don't think,
uh,
what,
how valuable a little things are.
The thank you's,
the smiles that taking time to listen.
I had a situation,
I still grapple with this when people ask,
stop you on the street and asked for money.
So we were,
we were having lunch yesterday and a lady came up and she asked if she could
spare some money.
She wanted to get something to eat or drink.
So I gave her $5 and I said,
now I hope you used a $5 on what you said you were going to do.
So she points in is a little grocery store,
a few store doors down.
She comes back,
shows me to drink and to $3 change.
And so wow.
So we,
it was a win for both of us.
But uh,
I grapple with this thing about do I give them some money and uh,
uh,
do I not.
But in this case,
I mean I really felt good that,
that I was able to do the,
do something for her and she did something for me cause she made me feel good
that,
that I could trust what she really did help fortify my mind that I should
probably be giving more instead of less.
We'll you've given a lot
in a lot of ways in many years of your life and,
and certainly one capacity is that a coach.
Uh,
and we were,
we're educator or teacher and we could spend days and hopefully we will,
hopefully we'll get to know each other even better and spend more time together.
But for now I thought we might jump forward at least from your childhood stories
to the Olympics,
1984 and
there are many different angles we could take to,
to get into this.
But,
uh,
I suppose where I want to start,
there's,
so it's so many different things that I want to touch on,
but since we were talking about communicating and phrasing and words,
could you,
uh,
could you share the motivational quote that you came up with at that time?
And I think it's,
each one of us has a relative who gave his life for this country.
The least we can do is give 40 minutes of ourselves.
Yes.
That was,
that's actually a Bob Knight quote.
Uh,
and,
um,
was
the motivating force because
when you stop and think about it,
very seldom in our lifetime does our country ever come to us and say,
we need you.
It's,
it's always the exact opposite that we,
that we're looking for something from the government.
But I felt that this was a unique opportunity,
uh,
that the country was basically saying to the team and the coaches that we need
you and we need you to bring back a gold medal force.
And so this,
this was a unique opportunity for us to serve our country.
And I can remember vividly in the months leading up to the 84 Olympics in Los
Angeles,
I would envision that we going to win the gold medal and we were going to be
standing there and,
and,
uh,
and the hear the national anthem play and to be at attention and look at the
American flag.
I know that w we're in a different era now in a different time,
but the reality was this is how I felt.
And so I,
I grew up in an era where where my grandma taught,
uh,
America,
right or wrong America,
whatever the problems are,
we'll work them out.
But,
but at the end of the day,
we're an American.
And so I,
I envision,
what was it going to be like when we stood there and received a gold medal and,
and,
um,
heard the national anthem played in you and you had the satisfaction of saying
to yourself a mission accomplished.
And it was,
it was one of the most unique experiences I've ever had in my life to,
to be in a position where you could represent your country and you could,
uh,
feel,
have a good feeling about it.
I,
I'm sure there'll be a lot of people who will question why I felt that way,
but that's the truth of the matter.
And I was chatting with a Ryan or texting with Ryan last night after he had
dinner with you.
And,
uh,
he was,
he was peppering me with suggested topics,
which of course we have an over abundance of.
But one of the bullets here in the notes in front of me is that refers to you
leading the practice team to beating the Dream Team.
Can you elaborate on this place?
And what happened was,
uh,
for the first time in the history of the Olympics,
the United States decided not to use college players anymore,
but to use professional players in so that year the Olympics were in Barcelona
and Chuck daily was the head coach of the u us team.
And of course you had a,
I think the only player on that Dream Team that's not in the basketball hall of
fame right now is Christian Laettner was,
he was the only college player on the roster.
And you,
of course you had magic bird Barkley,
uh,
Jordan,
you name it was.
So chuck and I had been lifelong friends back from when he was in his system
that Duke,
and that was an assistant at Villanova.
And,
um,
he was a Pennsylvania and,
uh,
go up pucks a tawny.
So we had longstanding,
a authentic relationship.
So,
uh,
chuck decided that they wanted to put together a group of college players that
would,
would a scrimmage the dream team twice a day in practice.
And so he suggested that I be the coach.
And so cm Newton,
who was head of USA basketball at the time call me and asked if I would,
would be the coach of a team.
And I said,
I'd love to do it.
So they picked the players and Bobby Hurley and uh,
uh,
Chris Webber and a bunch of guys.
We only had eight players and Roy Williams and I coached the team together.
And so the first night that we had the scrimmage,
uh,
I think the NBA guys basically looked at it.
I says,
this is just a scrimmage in college guys.
And so they,
they,
they didn't really take it as serious as we did a college guys.
They were,
well,
we were all fired up.
This is a great opportunity.
So we scrimmaged for 37 minutes and,
and we actually beat them in the scrimmage.
And so,
uh,
the word got out and they were livid.
So one thing that happened,
um,
I picked one of my managers from USC to be a manager for our team.
And so when the,
when the practice ended,
Larry Burke came up to me and he said,
coach,
he said,
can you do me a favor?
I said,
sure.
What?
He says,
can you leave a van and the driver here or have somebody come back and pick me
up?
And so I,
so I'll leave.
One of the managers would have van.
So Larry hadn't shot the ball at well in the scrimmage,
so he stayed,
uh,
and,
and shot for an hour and 15 minutes straight.
And so I told them,
uh,
Dennis Johnson,
who was the manager,
I said,
when you get back,
let me know your back.
And so when he came to my room,
I said,
how'd it go?
He said,
coach,
he said,
it's unbelievable.
He said,
he just continually shot.
He said he only took one water break and he said he was drenched head to toe.
And he looked at me and he said,
coach,
if Larry Bird is doing this,
what should the average guy be doing?
And it was,
it was just a great experience.
Uh,
uh,
I,
so the next,
not the time we scrimmaged uh,
they were,
they were fired.
So we doubled the,
I'm embarrassed to say this,
we didn't score a field goal for the first night in minutes.
I mean,
they were on us like white on rice and they were,
they said,
oh,
you guys think you're hot as you know,
we're going to show you.
And Jordan was leading the pack and so they would determine,
okay,
you guys think you're good,
we're going to show you what,
what good is.
Uh,
so I want to talk about coaching a team.
and I,
I think the way I'd like to get into this,
I is by asking if you could maybe mention just one coach that you have been
impressed by,
alive or dead past,
present,
it doesn't matter.
And what impressed you about them?
Oh,
I would say to coaches who are,
I don't actually have to say three,
three coaches who have had an immense impact on me as a person,
as a coach.
My life would be a Bob Knight,
John Thompson and Lefty Jersey,
lefty Zell.
I was his assistant at the University of Maryland.
Uh,
he was the one who taught me,
uh,
who,
who fuel my passion for reading.
He was the one who,
who taught,
taught me that,
uh,
that you don't just read the sports section.
He actually got me into a system that I still a use when I go to the newspaper.
Now,
the last section of the newspaper,
I read his sports and that's something that started back with him.
He also told me the importance of reading the editorial page every day.
And He,
and then the other thing was he,
he,
he wanted us to be the best dressed staff in the ACC.
So I picked up a lot of habits,
uh,
from lefty,
that,
that I have to,
to this day,
John Thompson,
I grew up in the same neighborhood in Washington DC.
Um,
he had,
he's had so much influence on the way I think the w the way I act.
What I believe.
Um,
uh,
w the one thing I learned with John is when you're around John,
you're talk to listen ratio.
You're listen ratio should be 90%,
and the talk should be 10.
Because if it's any other way you've,
you,
you've lost a great opportunity to,
to learn and,
and to be taught.
Cause he's,
he's um,
he was,
John is a maverick thinker in the,
and he was a maverick thinker before the connotation even existed and the other
person,
Bob Knight
to sad,
absolutely amazing impact on why was that a summer league game as an assistant
coach at Villanova and halftime,
I go down to look at the scoreboard and the guy taps me on the back end and I
turned in,
he says,
hi,
my name's Bob Knight.
Assistant at West Coach was point and I say,
Hi George Raveling assistant at Villanova.
And from that moment on we had a lifelong friendship and that's how I ended up
being the assistant coach on the 84 Olympic team.
But maybe Bob's greatest gift to me was that he saw something that end made it I
never saw in myself.
And he was relentless to,
to make sure that I achieved that.
He,
he said to me,
George,
if we're going to survive in this profession,
we have to become an expert in some phase of the gate and you need to make
yourself an expert in some phase of the game.
Bob's was defense.
And so he said to me,
he said,
I know you speak a lot at clinics on rebounding.
That's your niche.
You've got to make yourself the foremost authority on the globe on rebounding.
And then he stayed after me on a phony call me one night.
He said,
hey,
I,
I looked it up in the,
in the,
uh,
library of Congress.
There's no book in the Library of Congress on rebounding.
So you've got a unique opportunity.
And so I still didn't believe that I could actually write a book.
And so he,
he,
Bob just stayed after me.
So finally he said,
write it,
write an outline and send it to me.
And then of course,
we didn't have a technology.
We did it.
So I wrote an outline and send it to them.
So little did I know he was setting me up before,
is the,
walk me through this.
And so the moral of this story is I ended up writing a book called,
uh,
one I work was a Rebounderz workshop and the,
and the,
and the other one's called war on the boards.
That was the thesis in the manuscript for the art of rebounding.
And I,
I've,
I've probably sold 100,000 copies over the years of the book,
but without Bob staying on me and being relentless and never accepting no,
he helped me find s something inside of me that I would have never in my life
ever thought I would have written a book and,
or even had the talent to do.
But he,
he saw something in me that other people didn't see in me.
And that's been a lot of,
uh,
of,
of the relevance for this magical carpet ride I've had in life.
People seeing something in me that I didn't see in myself,
my grandma's see and something that means sister Delores in something to me.
Uh,
my high school coach seeing something in me,
my co,
my,
uh,
my college coach Al Severance,
he said something Tim that out,
never ever forget one time he was talking to us and he said,
the first sign of intelligence is to admit that you don't know something.
And,
and,
uh,
here I am eight years old and,
and I,
I still remember him telling me this,
that it,
and,
and so I've learned so much everyone that including yourself have touched my
life and in a productive way.
If I don't read tools to the tight,
and I don't know her in about mastermind,
if I don't learn about mastermind,
I killed myself in 20 different relationships.
I,
uh,
I learned things about people that I didn't know.
So,
uh,
it's just been a blessing journey that you meet people who are willing to help
you continue to grow,
especially at 80 years.
Oh,
well now he,
you think Tim from s at 60 years old,
the thought process in America was you retire,
you get a gold watch and you live happily ever after.
But between 60 and 80 is it might be the most productive years of my life.
I've grown so much.
I'm,
I was 63 years old and I get appointed global,
uh,
director of sports marketing at Nike at 63 years old.
So how does you defied the odds?
Ex basketball coach,
black,
no business background and you're running,
you're running a fortune 500 category.
And,
uh,
and I can remember many times thinking that,
all of the four years I spent at Villanova,
uh,
I was an econ major in economics maybe.
And at that time,
they didn't call it this,
a business school called the school of Commerce and finance.
So I graduated with a degree in economics and I used to think,
God,
this is a waste of time.
I learned all this.
I'm never going to use it.
And little did I know that at 63 years old,
all this was going to come back to fruition and,
and it was going to be necessary.
And,
um,
so it,
it,
it did pay off.
And,
uh,
as I understand it,
the,
um,
the job offer a,
or at least you're beginning with Nike,
came through what seemed like a prank call from a Phil Knight.
At least that's what I read.
You started long before that when I went,
went to work full time for them.
I get this call and then we'll go back to the origin.
Uh,
I get a call one night and I answered the phone and the voice says,
this is Philip Knight.
And that's basically how filled always addresses it to this day.
If he calls,
he's going to say,
this is Philip Knight.
And so I for a moment,
Turley is somebody put me on.
So then I said,
uh,
is it really easy and it's full night?
And I said,
what's going on?
And he said,
uh,
just called to see if you'd be interested in coming to work for Nike full time.
And so we talked it through and I said,
well,
what do you want me to do?
And he said,
I want you to come.
And at that time,
like he had this,
this camp call the all American camp.
And he said,
I want you to upgrade it,
but I want,
I want to figure out how we can reach a younger kids.
And so I still have somewhere in storage,
the original presentation that I made to him to start a grassroots program.
At that time,
there was no such thing as a grass roots program.
And,
and so that was started me working full time.
But I actually started at Nike and,
and in 1978,
the Nike decides they're going to get college coaches to endorse their product
and they fly 11 of us to Los Vegas.
And,
uh,
Jerry talk,
Caney was one,
Jimmy Valvano and so forth.
And so John slusher Sr and Phil came and made the presentation to us and
essentially they would give you a compensation and all the product for you and
your,
your team.
And this is in [inaudible] 78.
And so,
um,
I was sitting beside Bill Foster,
who was coaching at Clemson at the time.
And so the,
the second day we had to make a decision.
And so part of it was they give you the compensation.
The compensation was 5,000 in cash or 5,000 in stock.
That the impediment,
it really wasn't as it turned out,
was if he took the stock,
he couldn't catch the stock for five years.
And at that time the stock was about six bucks.
And so bill foster leans over to me and he says,
George,
take to stock,
take the stock out.
I'll explain to you later.
He said,
all these [inaudible] going to take the cash.
And so the five year thing ended up being a disciplinary,
a factor,
because even if you wanted to,
you couldn't cash it.
So,
so then when the five years passed,
bill called me about six months before the due date,
and he said,
listen to me again,
don't cash the sock,
don't cash the stock.
Just let it roll over.
You got this far without,
you can get the rest of the way.
So anyway,
uh,
by the time I finally sold the stock,
it Wa it was up to 46 bucks and,
and,
and it's split.
And so,
but to go back,
I,
so that year in 78,
Nike,
since Bill Foster,
myself and Eddie Sutton to,
uh,
to China for a month to do clinics.
And so we went to a,
to peak king Shanghai in Guang Jo.
So at that time,
Beijing did not exist.
Subsequently,
Beijing,
it was peaking,
was replaced with Beijing,
but at that time,
uh,
it was called Peking.
And so we went and did these clinics in China.
And at that time it was highly communistic.
Everybody dressed the same,
the women dressed white blouse and olive green slacks and,
and the men had these little,
a Nehru jackets at olive green,
and they had a cap with the red star on it that could speak no English.
And so one day we're in Tenement Square and bill Foster's wife had a Polaroid
camera and she was taking pictures.
And so she took a picture of a group of Chinese people standing together,
conversating.
And so when,
then when we developed,
she showed it to him and they were,
it was like,
we might as well been from the moon day was so we couldn't tell what they're
saying.
But anyway,
there were so excited pointing and then more people came and they had no idea,
uh,
how this was transpiring.
So here's,
here's a,
an interesting story,
Tim.
So a Chinese gentleman steps out of the crowd and he comes up to me and he,
and he,
and he picks my hand up and he rubs my hand,
looks at his fingers.
And so it was a parent,
he had never seen a black person before in his life and he thought it was paint.
Wow.
And so he was rubbing to see if the paint,
cause he couldn't figure it out.
He'd never seen a black person before.
And it's just,
it's,
it's a story that's left an indelible mark on my,
my,
uh,
stay.
But it,
that was maybe one of the great trips of,
of all time.
I tell you one other quick story.
We're doing the clinic and in Shanghai and the,
and a interpreter comes up to me at the end of my lecture and he says,
coach,
he says,
uh,
this coach would like the bar you're rebounding book and he'll bring it back in
the morning.
So I thought he just wanted to take it home and read it.
So the next morning and comes back.
Sure enough,
it gives me the book and he's got 25 copies of it overnight.
The 25 guys in a book and it gave me mine back.
Welcome to China.
See you started working full time at Nike.
It's at age 63.
Is that right?
Well,
no,
I actually,
I took the global,
uh,
sports marketing job at 63.
I actually had put in about eight years in,
in developing this grassroots,
uh,
program at Nike.
And then subsequently I got this opportunity to,
to,
to be the global director.
And you mentioned a familiar name to a lot of people.
Michael Jordan earlier from the Dream Team.
And I've seen a photograph of you with a very young Michael Jordan,
uh,
sub read that you're the one who actually convinced Michael Jordan does signed
with Nike,
uh,
or certainly one of the driving factors there.
Can you do,
could you share that story?
I don't know if I would go that far,
but I was a cotton doing,
uh,
so early,
Eh,
at the Olympic trials,
uh,
sunny Vic Carroll,
who was then a heading up Nike basketball and Phil had came to me and they said,
hey,
can you see if you can get Michael to visit with us?
And so,
uh,
we were still training in Bloomington.
So I,
I brought the subject up with Michael.
What happened was,
uh,
I don't know exactly how this happened,
but Vern Fleming,
who was on a team from Georgia,
Patrick Ewing,
myself and Michael,
we were inseparable.
The whole and Olympic experience.
We went everywhere together.
We,
and we were like the four Amigos.
We'd go to Mcdonald's,
we go to the movies,
a shopping mall,
wherever we did was always the four of us.
And,
and so I developed a really a unique relationship with Michael.
So from time to time I would bring it up to him about the Nike thing without
being overbearing.
And in the very beginning said,
coach,
he says,
I have no interest in Nike.
I'm an Adidas guy.
I'm going to go to a date as a,
I don't even like their product.
And so every now and then I would bring it up and he would say,
coach,
I'm telling you,
man,
it's a waste of time.
I'm going to be an Adidas guy.
So now we get through the,
uh,
we're at the Olympics and we get through pool play and we have a day off.
And so Sonny Vaccaro calls and he says,
Hey,
can you bring Michael,
get him to come over and meet,
meet me at Tony Roma's in Santa Monica.
So I bring it up to Mike and I think just out of frustration to get rid of me,
he just said,
okay,
I'll go.
So we're going over in the car and that he said,
coaches,
so I'm only doing this for you.
He said that,
uh,
it's a waste of time or whatever a Nike offers me,
I'm going to take it to a date as significant data.
Some matches it.
That's it.
That's who I want to be.
So to fast forward,
he ends up,
him and his mom and dad and David Fall come up to Nike for a visit.
And the meeting is as successful,
but it didn't move the needle because Michael was still convinced that he should
go with,
uh,
under Armour.
But part of the Nike,
Adidas,
I mean,
I'm sorry,
w w w was the Datas.
And so part of the deal was,
at that time there was no such thing as a signature shoe.
And so David Falk came up with this idea of Air Jordan.
And so,
uh,
and Nike would make a signature shoe that would be marketed under this,
this logo of Air Jordan.
And so when the meeting goes,
well,
we think we got a shot.
And so tutors,
word Michael took the deal back,
or David took the deal back to Adidas and Adidas passed on it because of the
signature shoe thing,
because they didn't feel there was any market for it and,
and uh,
and they still made him an offer,
but,
but they,
they wouldn't go on the signature shooting.
And,
and I,
I,
if I remember correctly,
Michael was getting 5 cents a,
a royalty on the shoe.
So at any rate,
uh,
Michael ended up accepting the,
the offer from Nike and as they say on television,
the restless history.
But here we are today and,
and Jordan brand is,
is a business of it.
So and so,
so like there's Nike Inc and then you have these subsets at Hurley,
converse,
Jordan brand.
So Jordan brand is the second biggest seller of basketball shoes in the world.
Basketball shoes,
other than Nike Inc and a,
they sell more basketball shoes and under Armour or,
or Adidas.
And so here you go,
back to 84 in here today.
Uh,
he sits at the head of one of the most profitable sport sports footwear
companies in,
in the world.
And what's interesting,
which historians will put in their rightful place one day is Nike was the first
fortune 500 company to take a black male and make them the face of their
company.
And then you,
I'm sure you're familiar with the spike Lee ads and all those things like that.
And so there was a huge a risk in some ways.
But one time I mentioned to Michael About Nike taken a risk.
And so he quickly came back to me,
he says,
Nike took a risk.
Hey,
I took a risk.
I see you,
you spent so much time
teaching and guiding and cultivating players and uh,
people who work for you and the people around you.
Uh,
I had read,
and please feel free to correct this,
but that,
um,
you've said the most important conversation is the one you have with yourself.
Yeah.
So could you,
could you elaborate on that please?
Because I,
I,
I've,
I think that self talk is,
and I'm not sure that's what you're referring to,
but so,
so terribly important.
Uh,
so I'd love,
love to hear you just elaborate on that
or I've gotten,
the more I've come to
the conclusion that the,
the,
that the conversation that you have every day with yourself as you characterize
itself talk is so vital.
It's far more important than the conversations you have with those around you.
And the best part about the conversation with yourself is you're in total
control of that conversation.
You can craft the conversation any way you want to.
And so I try to have at least 90% of the conversations that I have with myself,
which I have two or three times a day that it's a positive self talk.
If I start to linger on to something a negative,
then what I'll do is I'll deal with it and discounted.
Uh,
for example,
uh,
since I'm Catholic,
I'll make this confession.
So this morning when I got up your reputation so impeccable that I was,
I was,
uh,
I got up at five.
I'm really nervous.
I'm thinking to myself,
God,
what if I,
if I do a bad job,
I'll be so embarrassed.
And so the minute I started thinking that I said,
nope,
that's not it.
Get fired up man.
You're going to do it.
And I'm so I'm in,
I'm in,
I'm in the bathroom and I'm,
I'm,
I'm doing this motivational talk for myself to eradicate any doubt that I have.
And,
and,
and I keep saying to myself,
you got to go in here.
You got to give me your best shot.
You can do it.
So I'm getting myself fired up for it.
And this is out loud.
Yeah,
I'm in because uh,
uh,
I really spend as much time as probably at least I wouldn't say probably once a
day I'll find an hour to just go someplace and sit by myself.
And all I do is take a notebook and is putting in a pen in front of me and not
just sit there and think whatever comes into my mind.
And then I start to fixate on those things and,
or I'll write down notes as a result of something that I think or are write out
a strategy.
For example,
the way I govern my day,
Tim is,
is,
uh,
I get up in the morning and I put my two feet beside the bed and I say to
myself,
okay,
George,
you only have two choices today.
These are the only two choices that you have.
And you got to make one.
And the two choices are to be happy or to be very happy and the,
and there is no other choice.
And so then I start to plan a plan out my day and I'm on.
And so I have these,
these points of focus energy,
uh,
a time and energy management,
time management,
environmental management,
productivity.
And to me,
productivity is a byproduct of the other three.
So how do I manage my,
my energy every day sorted?
I can,
I can be at maximum efficiency.
So one of the things I try to do is declutter my mind.
I won't do any more than four things a day.
And it,
it,
it reverts back to something,
one of the presidents at Nike,
Charlie Denson said one time in a leadership meeting,
he said,
let me ask you guys this,
would we be better off doing 25 things good or will we be better off doing six
things?
Great.
And so to me,
to make simplify my day,
I will not do more than four things.
I,
I tried to limit to meetings to two.
And if it's too,
one of them is usually a breakfast meeting.
When I go into the office I have,
I have a total commitment once I get into the office to be totally focused on,
on business matters,
try to be as disciplined as I can,
not to get on the telephone and,
and also to meet with,
with the two people that work with me.
We meet every single day and we talk as a team because I want us to function as
a team.
I want each person's opinion to be valued.
If one person happens to be 50 years younger than me,
so what their,
their,
their uh,
their opinion is valuable to me.
I respect everyone's knowledge and I think to myself,
they know something that I don't know.
And so I,
I want it valued our opinions.
So,
uh,
we meet every day as a staff.
We talk about things and,
and uh,
it helps me grow and,
and it keeps my day simplified.
I try to clean,
uh,
try to once a week have a,
a personal audit.
I,
I go back through the week and an audit my week and,
and,
and make course corrections along the way.
So that's when I really get into the self talk part is having these little
mental audits that my life is just not going on.
And on and on.
I,
I try to evaluate am I making progress?
What am I doing that's good?
What am I doing that's not working?
And then make those course corrections.
And at 80 years old,
I tried to hold myself to the most severe standards.
Uh,
and,
and I,
I just despise the idea of retirement.
And I think that it's,
it's the biggest farce that's ever been predicated on us is this idea of
retirement.
Cause the first thing that happens to you when you retire,
you're physically and then you retire mentally and then you're,
you're,
you just taken up residence in,
in,
in society.
And I don't ever want to be a resident of society.
I want to be a contributor to society.
When you,
you seem like you're just getting warmed up.
Uh,
we have lots of energy.
What are you most excited about,
uh,
these days in working on?
Well,
what I get most excited about is just waiting.
When you're 80 years old,
you gave you damn sure better be excited that you wake up the next morning and
you have a growth opportunity.
I'm still trying to understand like most of us,
what the,
what the future is an a be like,
and how can I get to the future first and what's the future gonna be like?
But I read a lot of books and talk to a lot of people,
but,
uh,
I don't know if anybody can really tell you what the world's going to be like
five years from now,
not 10 years from now,
but five years from now.
Uh,
we're,
we're in a society where it'd be,
who's all of us to be comfortable with,
with change and to be comfortable with being uncomfortable.
If you could,
metaphorically speaking,
put
anything on a billboard,
not commercial,
but a message,
a quote,
a word,
a question.
Somebody else's quote could be anything to get out to millions or billions of
people.
What,
what type of message or word or quit or anything might,
might you put on that billboard?
I would say if I could put up a billboard,
the,
and the message to people,
the quote would be,
if it is to be,
it's up to me because at the end of the day,
uh,
each of us have an individual responsibility to ourselves and to,
to our society,
to,
to figure out ways to be positive difference makers.
And,
and it all starts in life.
Uh,
uh,
I'm fondest reminding myself that nobody's going to row your boat for you,
but you,
you got to get in and you got to roll your boat to the other side of the,
the late.
And so I would remind people,
as I said,
if it is to be,
it's up to me.
And that's something that,
uh,
I had on my office door,
I had a big sign at Washington state,
I had it on my office door.
It's something that I've tried to,
to make an indelible mark on my brain that it's up to me if changes about the
best,
the most authentic change takes place
within yourself.
And so a,
B,
and oftentimes in life,
Tim,
as you know,
the most important person you ever get to lead is yourself.
And if you can't lead yourself,
how are you going to lead other people?
And so I would like to challenge people to,
to,
to start to look within before they look out is to look within and,
and w and what are,
what are the things that I can do to,
to,
uh,
to be a positive change in Mike maker in my life and in the life of others.
So when we talk about being a positive change maker,
the thought process is this is about trying to change society.
But when I hear people all say to something that had changed a world,
what would,
if you want to do something that's going to change the world,
you change first.
And that's going to,
that's it.
And if everybody started to feel that way,
we'd have this huge movement of change that would be authentic
here.
Here,
I'm getting all fired up and get it that coach.
Uh,
I want to be respectful of your time.
So I think we're going to wrap up shortly here,
but is there anything else you'd like to share?
Any other parting words?
Certainly people can find you at George Raveling on Twitter,
Instagram,
Facebook,
linkedin website,
coach George raveling.com.
I encourage everybody to check it out,
but is there,
is there anything else that you'd like to mention?
Yes.
He
pulled me off the hook because all my Alma,
you full advisors said,
coach,
make sure you tell people how to,
how to stay in touch with you.
But it's all technology has helped me be,
uh,
create a platform of sharing the,
try to share one thing.
My grandma's,
she said to me one time,
she was correcting me and,
and I also will smart Aleke.
And so she looked at me in a stern way and she said,
she said,
boy,
let me tell you something.
I know where the potholes are in life and maybe if you listen to me,
I can help you avoid stepping into them.
So at 80 years old,
I,
I think of my grandma and I say,
Hey,
I know where a lot of the potholes are in life and maybe I can tell you where
they are and share my life experiences what you,
so that you don't have to step into those potholes.
And so that's what I try to do is,
is to,
to share.
A old guy told me one time,
nothing in life is of any value unless you can share it with other people.
And so that is the essence of me at 80 years old.
What is it that I have that I can share with others and what can I give away?
I,
Eh,
I don't even know if I said this to my wife yet.
So you,
you're going to be the beneficiary of,
of,
of a movement.
I now have committed that I'm going to try to give away most of my personal
belongings and I'm going to give away all my clothes and my books.
I'm alone.
I'm trying to give away as much stuff as I can to simplify my life.
I can only wear one pair of shoes.
I can only wear one pair of underwear.
I don't need all these things.
And so I'm going to rid myself of all these,
these material things that I thought were important that at eight years old,
the money's not that I learned.
Money's not that important.
Uh,
collecting things are not that important.
how you dress.
All those things become a us,
what I call surrender.
Someone tells you what time they get up in the morning,
what time they go to bed,
what to eat,
what the dress or how to.
And so we ended up being prisoners of someone else's expectations.
So I want to live to whatever time I have left and I want to,
as Martin Luther King said,
free at last,
free at last.
Thank God Almighty,
we are free at last.
I just want to be free of all these,
these,
these fences that society's put up around me and I want to try to find out where
are my outer limits.
And once you take down the fences,
you allow a person to seek their outer limits.
And that's what I'm trying to do at eight years old is to figure out where my
outer limits are and to keep reaching for.
Well coach I hope to have many more conversations with you.
So,
uh,
thanks so much sir.
Thank you.
And uh,
may you,
may you be around for at least another 80,
and what a gift of the conversation.
Thank you.
I appreciate you giving me the time and for everybody listening for links to
everything we talked about,
certainly where you can find coach Raveling online and learn what he's up to in
addition to the books that we discussed and everything else you can find all of
that linked in the show notes at tim.blog/podcast what a ride.
And uh,
everybody out there.
Until next time.
Thank you for listening.
Hey guys,
this is Tim again.
Just a few more things before you take off.
Number one.
This is five bullet Friday.
Do you want to get a short email from me?
Would you enjoy getting a short email from me every Friday that provides a
little morsel of fun before the weekend and five bullet Friday is a very short
email where I share the coolest things I've found or that I've been pondering
over the week.
That could include favorite new albums that I've discovered.
It could include Gizmos and gadgets and all sorts of weird shit that I've
somehow dug up in the,
uh,
the world of the esoteric as I do.
It could include favorite articles that I've read and that I've shared with my
close friends.
For instance,
it's very short.
It's just a little tiny bite of goodness before you head off for the weekend.
So if you want to receive that,
check it out.
Just go to four hour work week.com that's four hour work week.com all spelled
out and just drop in your email and you'll get the very next one.
And if you sign up,
I hope you enjoy it.
This episode is brought to you by freshbooks.
Freshbooks has become the goto cloud accounting software for literally millions
of small business owners who found a faster,
more efficient and much less stressful way to deal with their numbers and
ultimately this helps you to focus on what you are best at.
It is used by many of the fastest growing startups I've invested in or advise
and it's equally used by many of the best freelancers I work with on a daily or
weekly basis.
It is one of the easiest ways to send invoices,
get paid,
track your time and track your clients if you're self employed and managing
business sometimes means wrestling with spreadsheets,
crumbled receipts and other scattered pieces.
Freshbooks can really help.
Freshbooks allows you to do many,
many different things very easily.
Preparing and sending a polished branded invoice takes about 30 seconds.
You can set yourself up to receive online payments from your clients in about
two clicks,
which on average we'll get you paid twice as fast they're new proposals.
Feature means you can include a project summary and timeline is part of your
estimate.
There are many,
many other things.
Tracking your time,
the quick proposals that I mentioned,
formatting free,
super easy,
late payment reminders so you don't have to chase people.
Automatic expenses,
sharing files and messages with your client's award winning customer service.
They are extremely responsive.
The interface is super intuitive and there's almost no learning curve,
so in short it's easy.
It saves you time and right now freshbooks is offering an unrestricted 30 day
free trial.
For all of my listeners to claim yours,
check it out.
Go to freshbooks.com/tim and enter Tim Ferris in the how did you hear about us
section and that is funky.
Spell t I m f.
E R.
R.
I s.
S.
So again going to freshbooks.com/tim and enter Tim Ferris in the,
how did you hear about us section?
Check it out.
This episode is brought to you by audible,
which has the largest selection of audio books on the planet.
I've used audible for many years and I've several audio books to recommend right
off the bat.
If you're looking for a new one,
we're ready player one by Ernest climb.
You may have heard of it,
the Tao of Seneca by Seneca.
If you want to hear my favorite collection of letters of all time as well as the
graveyard book by Neil Gaiman,
which is a fiction book I used to reintroduce nonfiction purists to the beauty
and truth and enjoyment,
affection graveyard book.
It is incredible and I like the version that Neil reads himself,
but the entire ensemble cast is also fun.
Audible members get a credit every month,
good for any audio book in the store,
regardless of price and unused credits roll over to the next month.
So if you didn't like your audio book,
no problem.
You can exchange it,
no questions asked.
Plus your books are yours to keep with audible.
You can go back and relisten to anytime,
even if you cancel your membership and for some books,
again,
graveyard book by Neil Gaiman.
I've listened many,
many times.
You may even just start over as soon as you finish it the first time.
Audible also helps you to listen to more books by letting you switch seamlessly
between devices.
Picking up exactly where you left off,
whether it's on your phone,
through your car,
from a tablet or at home on an Amazon Echo,
whatever.
You can get through tons of books,
hands in ice free while doing almost anything.
So that is part of the beauty of audio.
It is a secondary activity when you're walking the dog cooking,
whatever it might be.
Audible content includes an unmatched selection of audiobooks.
Original audio shows,
news,
comedy,
and much more from leading audio book publishers,
Broadcasters,
Entertainers,
magazine and newspaper publishers and business information providers.
Maybe that's what I am,
a business information provider and right now audible is offering listeners of
this podcast a free audiobook with a 30 day trial memberships.
Check it out.
Go to audible.com forward slash Tim and browse the unmatched selection of audio
programs.
Download a title free and start listening in.
Super simple.
Go to audible.com forward slash Tim or text Tim to 500 500 on your telephone to
get started today.
Check it out.